[Music]
nicki minaj's son wants her to know he's
proud of her latest achievement
you like your voice
that's cool
okay so maybe he's a little young to
understand how billboard charts work but
that didn't stop him from celebrating
nicki's history making single super
freaky girl
[Music]
the track debuted in the number one spot
on billboard's hot 100 making it the
first solo female rap track to top the
chart since 1998.
well that was that's always the goal i
always want to be great at anything i do
and naturally she had to call in some
reinforcement to toast the good news
[Music]
and who better than the super bass
rapper's two-year-old son whom she
endearingly calls papa bear
nikki shared the sweet moment on
instagram and it is cuteness overload
watch the adorable toddler wrap himself
up in his mom's balloons in her
signature color pink
[Music]
in the caption nikki thanks her team for
the beautiful surprise and her record
label for sending some gorgeous flowers
but don't get it twisted nikki says the
star of the show here obviously papa
bear
writing mama loves you papa bear you
make every single moment worth it
but the celebrations are just getting
started yes
up next nikki is co-hosting the mtv
video music awards alongside ll cool j
and jack harlow
the anaconda rapper is also receiving
the coveted video vanguard award i'm
very excited about the success we'll
have to wait and see if papa bear joins
his mama on her big night for even more
good times
nikki's little boy has popped up many
times on her social media and we can
only hope the award show festivities
call for more moments like this
say me and mama laughed at that
[Music]